Hi, good morning.
So the salaried employee
example.
Uh, did soujanya talk about that
in the webinar for amortized
analysis?
Yeah.
So where exactly you guys?
Uh did not understand it.
OK.
Who I think I will quickly
describe it.
I mean, it's not very important.
It is not directly there in the
course, but it's important for
you to know about those things.
So yeah, I think, uh, if you
consider our own expenses,
right.
So for example, say this is the
year end season, and I might
want to go for a vacation,
right?
And let's assume that you are
going on a big vacation.
And let's assume we are going to
spend a bomb on it and say, say,
three to five lakes.
You're spending on this
vacation, so that is the maximum
you have spent in this year in
every month.
If you see in December, you have
spent about 5,00,000 because you
have taken a trip.
That is the worst case, right?
Worst case you are spending
5,00,000 a month.
But does that mean every month
you are going to spend 5 bucks?
Yeah.
Anyone real quick?
Every month you have spent about
8:20, thousand, 30,000 and so
on, but certainly in December
because you have taken a
vacation, you have, you know,
also maybe you have paid your
next some fees and all that and
you have spent around 5,00,000
and that is the worst case and
if you consider N months it is N
into 5,00,000 and that is what
is the worst case and if you
consider worst case complexity
big O notation that is correct
right.
Going by that logic, you can
tell that you know here spend
5,00,000 in this month.
Maybe he's going to spend
5,00,000 every month, so that is
the worst case which is also not
wrong, right?
That is worst case, but in real
life, if I ask you, are you
going to do that for every
month?
You guys told me that.
No, I will actually match it up
and I will not be spending that
much every month, right?
Even in algorithms also that is
what also happens that the worst
case is not going to always
happen in certain algorithms,
right?
So that is what is called as
amortized analysis.
Meaning, whenever we want to
keep our analysis tight, right.
Uh, and not very.
Pessimistic telling that you
know this is what is the worst
case and this is what is going
to always happen in those cases
you can use amortized analysis
where you can tell that you know
what there are hundred
operations.
I mean the same operation is
happening 100 times in one or
two of those operations.
The complexity goes very high,
whereas all other times it is
normal.
So because of only that one or
two bad operations, I should not
deem the whole data structure to
be bad, right?
If you consider that RA
insertion alright, let me you
know give a simple example of I
have a small array of five
elements.
So I want to insert into that
array.
So what are the complexity to
insert the first number?
I go to array of zeroth
location.
I just put my number there.
So what was the complexity
constant right?
Again, I want to insert the next
element I go it's this constant
again, third element, 4th
element, Fifth element.
Now there is a problem, right?
Because I'm not able to insert
now because the whole array is
full, so at that point, what
should I be doing when data
structure is full?
What is the very obvious choice
that we have to do?
If it's linguist, there was no
problem because it can
dynamically grow.
But here, since it was an array
I my array is exhausted so I'll
have to increase the size.
Very good new array, right?
I cannot increase the length as
in when I go in an array because
the next location might not have
space in memory.
So I should create a new array,
so I create a new array
somewhere in memory, ideally
double the size and then I copy
all these elements again into
it.
So it is all extra work right?
I'm creating a new array and
then I'm copying all these
existing file elements into it
and then I'm inserting the 6th
element.
So far, this particular
insertion was the complexity
still constant, or was the
complexity N because you had to
copy all the elements and then
you are inserting this new
element but it perfect.
What about the 7th element
again?
Yeah, 7th element.
It's again, go back now that
array size has become ten,
right?
Because 5I doubled it.
Now it's 10.
So for the 6th element, again
there was a problem because I
had to copy all the elements,
then the 6th element I had to
insert, but again for 7th
element.
What is it?
I'll be having space in daray.
I'll just go to a of, you know,
six.
I'll put my element there.
What about the 8th element?
What about the 9th element for
all these?
Again, it has become normal,
right?
It is a constant complexity.
Right.
Again, there will be a problem
when the array gets filled
right?
I'll have to double it.
I'll make the array says AS20.
I'll copy all this 10 elements.
Then there will be one problem.
Again, it will get bit normal
right for inserting the 12th
element, 13th element 14151617
and all.
It will be again back to just a
constant complexity, so this bad
operation is it coming always is
every insert a bad insert like
you know complexity of north or
is it just happening here and
there it's just happening here
and there right only when the
array is exhausted at that point
I'm having that problem where
complexity goes high but all
other times it is still normal.
So this amortized analysis tells
you that just because there is
that bad operation, but that
doesn't happen frequently, that
happens only rarely.
Because of that, we should not
deem the whole data structure to
be bad.
I should not tell that inserting
in an array is N square, right?
Because worst case it is north
and I'm inserting N elements, so
it is North Square complexity.
We should not be doing that
right because we are.
We are very pessimistic in it,
right?
We're telling that every
operation is bad and it is going
to take more, but that is not
the real situation.
So that is where amortized
analysis comes in.
So the whole philosophy of
amortized analysis comes in when
the same operation is repeated
again and again, right?
It is not different different
steps.
It is the same insertion only,
but sometimes it is normal.
Some rare cases the complexity
goes high, but because of that
rare situations we should not
deem the whole data structure to
be bad or having a larger
complexity.
And this philosophy is called
you're amortized analysis.
So what will be the final
complexity for?
It has been the normal.
You should just tell it As for
inserting one element in array.
It is constant and for inserting
N elements it is big of north.
Yeah.
Is that right, Krishna?
Then this is also average.
Is it related to Theta notation?
No, no, no.
It is independent only, so we
are just telling that on an
average and then Irene
insertion, it is all the same.
It is not, you know, because at
some times only rarely it picks
up, so this is not the average
analysis.
Yeah, this is still worst case
analysis only, but then there's
a special case of amortization.
Yeah.
When the same operation is again
and again performed.
Yeah, it does.
It throw some light all of you.
And we ignore these during
analysis, right?
Yes.
So yeah, you can ignore that.
This is slightly higher concept.
Yeah, it is.
Not just a basic worst case, but
we are telling you the same
operation is happening again and
again.
Then how do you go about, you
know, doing it?
Pull.
Vivek, just for another minute
and then we will get started,
yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
SURBHI I'll get it uploaded.
Yeah.
So I think Soujanya has
forgotten it.
I will ask her to upload it and
also put an announcement.
Yeah.
Cool.
I think it's good time for us to
get started.
We'll just have a recap and we
will get started.
And yeah, there's also our
message.
Essentially we are saying they
we deem, say 2IN into two plus
uh.
The fact that two into N square
is a coefficient so that small
SHINDE is not tight bound.
So I didn't really quite get
that, but let's come back to
that, Rajesh.
Yeah.
So let's I will complete.
Go ahead with this and we will
come back to that amortization
again.
So there's a good explanation
about it, even your text, but we
will come back to it, yeah.
So what did we do in the last
class?
Oh, OK well canvas.
So is it there?
The webinar slides?
Yeah.
So what exactly did we do in
trees?
We did a lot of things.
Yeah.
So we got introduced to what is
trees.
It is a hierarchical data
structure.
Why do we need it?
We took a lot of terminologies,
I hope you remember that.
Yeah.
And then we also got started
with the different operations
and also about the different
types of trees, right, which was
very important. Yeah.
What is the binary tree?
Binary tree.
Someone who can have at most two
children, right?
All internal nodes at most two,
meaning it can even have you
know one or two.
But as proper binary tree was
the one where he has to have
exactly two children, right?
And then you had complete binary
tree which was very important.
Complete binary tree is A1 where
until the last but one level it
is completely filled.
Meaning in level 0 there can
only be one node.
It is there in level one.
There can be 2 nodes.
It is there in L2.
It can be 2 power two which is
4.
All four are there, and in the
last level it is not fully
filled.
That's fine, but nodes are
filled from left to right, so
this is first.
Then there's a second.
Then this node should have, and
so on.
It should not be somewhere in
the middle like this and so on,
right?
And how do you represent a
complete binary tree in a
computer?
Yeah.
Do you remember that part?
Maybe it's a complete binary
tree like this?
Which mechanism should we use?
Should we use an array or should
we use a linked list?
We should be using a array.
We need not use link list and so
on because if you use an array
we are still not going to waste
any space, right?
And how was that representation
all of you real quick, you draw
the complete binary tree, you
start the indexing with one.
Yeah, very good.
Yeah, you will start it from one
you will number it from top to
bottom left to right and then
you will create an array and
whatever numbers that you had
put that becomes your indices
and inside that you actually put
your elements and you are done
and for any element the left
child of it will be in two
position right child will be in
two I plus one and parent will
be I by two the floor value
right it was very simple stuff
but again we had taken this
example that if it is not a
complete binary tree then what
happens then what would happen
is if you take the same
mechanism if you start numbering
it from top to bottom left to
right you will realize that in
this case A doesn't have a right
child at all right and that C
will again not have two children
at all.
But you should imagine that such
nodes are there and you should
number it right 123 is not
there, 4567 is not there again
8-9 are not there and so on.
You should number it in that way
and then if you translate that
into your array, all those
positions will be empty.
So ideally what you are doing is
you are wasting a lot of space
for non existing nodes and we
are again considering those to
be a position because otherwise
those formulas will not work
right this two, I2I plus one and
so on will work only if all the
nodes are filled.
So we should imagine that three
is there and so on and we should
number it like that we should
not number the CS three.
Yeah.
Yes.
No, all of you are getting this.
Like this, although imaginary,
there is no node.
Here we are just putting some
dotted nodes and we are
numbering it as three.
Then you know 6-7 and so on.
But those positions are becoming
empty here.
So which is a bad approach?
We should not be doing that.
So only when it is a complete
binary tree or a perfect binary
tree, we will use a array.
In all other cases, we will use
a linked list and how is the
link list representation very
simple again right?
A binary tree is a linked data
structure.
Each node contains a data and a
pointer left, right and P the
left points to the left child of
the node right points to the
right child of the node.
P points to the parent of the
node, and if a child is not
there, right, maybe left is not
there, right?
Is not there.
That child is not there.
That will become null or null,
right?
And if a parent is missing, then
the P pointer will become nil.
What is the only case when this
can happen?
Yeah.
What is the only node where the
parent will be missing and
someone real quick tell that
route right?
So for root, the parent will not
be there, he'll be nil.
And what about leads for leaves?
Both the sides will be null,
right?
Because it doesn't have left
child also right child also.
So for leaves, both of them left
and right will be null.
So if you take an example like
this, each of them have 4
compartments, right?
This is the root.
His parent becomes empty because
he doesn't have a parent.
The left points to the left
child, the right compartment
points to the right child and
the actual data points to some
data value.
Similarly, if you go to this
particular node, its parent
points to the root, right?
Because that was its parent and
the left points to the left
child right point to the right
child, and this data element
points to Chicago, which is a
data element and so on.
So if you now want to insert a
new element, you will just
create a new node somewhere in
memory which will have you know
4 compartments.
If you want to make that as the
right child of this node, right
instead of this null, this will
point to our new node, our new
nodes parent compartment will
point to this node and then for
the new node you will put the
data elements, say India and
then for the new node India the
left and right will be empty,
right?
A simple insertion we'll be able
to do, and in some
representations, if you don't
want the parent if you just want
to start from root and go down
if you don't want to have a
parent pointer, you can also
have a representation like this,
but this is not very helpful.
This is the right way to do it
so that you have comprehensive
information, not just from root
to child, but if you are in a
leaf, you can also go back to
the root because you have the
parent informations catching
hold of that parent.
You will be able to go up the
tree also.
Yeah.
Is that clear?
Race.
All of you linked list
representation of a tree.
Yeah, simple stuff.
OK.
That being said, we have just
one last, you know, small
concept which is called
traversals, right?
So what exactly is that
traversal?
Right traversal simply means
walking through a data
structure.
I want to visit all the elements
of a data structure.
That simply means I'm
traversing.
Can I do a stack traversal?
Is that possible if I'm able to
do that, whose help will it
take?
Anyone in Stack who's that
element who's always?
Yeah, very good top element
using top element, I'll be able
to traverse all the elements.
Similarly for a queue, I'll
start from say front or I'll
start from say you know you're
rare.
I will just traverse all of them
by traversing we mean just
visiting all of them.
Either I can print them or I
can, you know, do some operation
on them.
Whatever.
It's just that I want to touch
all the elements I want to see
them.
So even for a tree, we will be
able to do that.
So to traverse or walk the
binary tree is to visit each
node in the binary tree exactly
once, right?
We should not be repeating them
exactly once and treat ourselves
are naturally recursive, and
there are three ways we can
traverse right for a normal
binary tree.
There are three ways which is
preorder, inorder and postorder.
If I first visit the route, then
go to the left side and then go
to the right side, it is called
preorder, yeah.
If I go to the left and then
finish all that left and then
root and then right that is in
order.
And if we complete the whole
left, whole right and then come
to the root, that is called post
order, right?
Have given some quick examples.
It is the same thing.
Yeah, I've just explained it.
It is the root left, right that
is nothing but preorder.
If it is left root right, that
is in order.
If it is left right root, it is
postorder right.
A very small example is here.
So this is a binary tree, right?
There is a node.
There are two children and I
have numbered them 123.
The preorder of this output will
be root, left, right, right.
SO123 will be the preorder
traversal output, whereas for
inorder we have to 1st go to the
left side, finish all the left,
then come to the root.
So in this case I'm having two,
then one, then three right 213
is the output for in order,
whereas for post order it will
be left right, root so it is 2/3
and one yes.
No, all of you got this.
The three traversals preorder,
inorder, postorder, right
preorder means it is first the
root process, the root first,
then the left side left means
not just the left child.
Yeah, it is.
The whole left sub tree and then
the right.
Similarly, in order means the
whole left side, then the root,
then the right and post order is
left, right, root, right.
So this was a very, very trivial
example.
You will have to actually do it
in this particular tree.
Yeah.
It's exactly what Krishna
wanted.
You should be practicing this in
the next deck.
I have this solution for this.
Yeah.
So I want you to first try this
and then you can also check
those answers.
Have you be able to do this?
But let me just give you a quick
hint.
If you are doing a post order
right, if you are doing a post
order on this tree, where will
this a be?
There in the output will it be
there in the beginning or will
it be there in the middle?
Or will it be there in the last?
Yeah, very good.
It'll be in the last because in
post order traversal we are
going to finish the whole left
side, then right side and then
come to the root.
So A is going to be in the last,
whereas what about preorder?
It is going to be the first one
and then in order it will be
somewhere in the middle, right?
Give it a shot.
Yeah, do practice this because
when I talk, it might seem
simpler, but only when you do
this it will be, you know, more
effective.
And then the very next, you know
slide, I have the answers for
these also.
So you can cross check the
answers.
Yeah.
Cool.
What about this question
represent the below in array and
linked list.
But I'm asking you a different
question for this type of a
tree.
Which representation is
effective?
Should I be using an array here
or should I be using a linked
list?
Yeah, you can.
You can expect such questions in
the quizzes.
Yeah, very good.
It is a linked list because this
is not a complete binary tree,
right there is Mt here.
There is empty here, so this is
not a complete binary tree, so I
will use a linked list.
Pull.
That's pretty much that we had
and we had to cover all this in
the last class and we just, you
know, pushed it for today.
Any doubt so far guys.
Apart from that, you know you
practicing that question.
Are there any other doubts or
are you good?
Well, if that's it, then, uh,
welcome to the fifth contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design.
And today we will start a new
concept called heaps.
Yeah, very interesting.
Yeah.
And we'll also see some
applications of heap like
heapsort and priority queues and
so on.
Maybe if possible today.
Otherwise, in the next class.
We already had a recap of what
we did in the last class, right,
which was trees.
Today we'll have a look at what
is the heap, what are the
different types, what are the P
fication, how do you build a
heap?
How do you insert something?
How do you remove something and
all that?
Right.
It's a very, very important
topic.
It's a beautiful data structure,
so I want you all to focus and
as I told the answers of those 3
traversals are here.
So you can practice and then
come to this particular slides.
Yeah, and there are many
applications of binary tree.
I've just listed a couple of
them here, like databases,
right?
If you have heard about indexing
in databases, yeah, any of you,
there's something called as
primary indexing, secondary
indexing, right, all those you
know, database concepts.
You can actually view those
indexing as binary trees.
Yeah, it's called B3B plus tree
and so on.
So in indexing it is used in
video games you know trees are
being used, every move can be,
you know, mapped as a tree.
You know Huffman coding, we will
learn in this course later,
right?
And a lot of other AI
applications also use trees
inside them.
Yeah, cool.
That being said, let's go to our
heap.
Yeah.
So something like this?
Have you seen the heap of
clothes like this?
Maybe kids do this, or some of
us also may do this, just, you
know, dumb things which might
look like a heap of thing,
right?
So what really is a heap?
Yeah, a heap is a special tree
based data structure that
satisfies the following special
heap properties.
So first thing first, it is
starting the whole definition
starts with.
It is a special tree, so can I
call it as a tree?
First of all, how many of you
agree?
Someone just blindly, you know,
tells you that heap is a tree.
Do you agree or not?
You should be telling yes.
Firstly, it is a tree, but it
has certain special qualities or
special properties.
What are those properties?
There are two properties, one is
the shape property and one is
the heap property, right?
So any three that is given to
you, yeah, you will inspect
these two properties and if
these two properties are
satisfied, then that becomes a
heap.
Is it making sense for all of
you?
Yeah.
These are all very, very simple
concepts, but nine out of 10
students make mistakes.
They have misconceptions about
this which I don't want you to
have, right?
It's a normal tree, but it has
these two special qualities.
Or these two properties?
Any tree that is given to you if
you inspect it.
I live.
These two properties are
satisfied in it then that is
qualifying to become a heap.
No.
Let's see each of these two
properties share property.
He data structure is always a
complete binary tree, which
means all the levels of the tree
are fully filled till the last
but one level and at the last
level H the nodes are filled
from left to right, right?
This is a complete binary tree.
All of you know what is a
complete binary tree.
We just revised it.
You all learned it in the last
class, so that is the first
property if a non complete
binary tree is given, then there
is no way it can be a heap.
Yeah, we're still clear the
moment someone gives you a tree
which is not a complete binary
tree right away, you can reject
it.
You can tell that this cannot be
a heap if it is a complete
binary tree, then you will go do
the second check, which is the
heap property, right?
What does the heap property all
nodes are either greater than or
equal to or less than or equal
to each of its children?
Yeah.
What does it mean if the parent
nodes are greater than their
children?
Then such a heap is called as
Max heap, so the root of any sub
tree holds the greatest value in
the subtree.
Similarly, the opposite of it,
if the parent nodes are smaller
than the children, then such a
heap is called a min heap.
So the root of any subtree holds
the least value in that subtree,
right?
For math lovers, for Max Heap is
nothing but for every node V
other than the root, because
root doesn't have a parent for
every other node, the parent
element will be greater than or
equal to its children, right?
It is for min heap apart from
the root for all the other
nodes, the parent node will be
smaller than the children.
This equal to is not very
commonly used, but technically
you can have it, but in most
applications that equal to will
not be there.
It will be strictly greater than
or less than, so let's put these
into, you know, practice.
Let's look at some examples,
right.
So let's look at this left side.
So is this a heap or not?
If it is a heap, it should be
either a min heap or a Max heap.
Otherwise it is not a heap at
all.
So if you have a look at this,
what is the first thing that
goes into your mind?
You will first check if this is
a complete binary tree or not.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yeah, let's not jump the bridge.
Let's take it step by step.
It is a complete binary tree.
Yeah.
Again, for all of you, why is it
not a complete binary tree?
Completely filled level 0 level
1-2 nodes can be there.
All two are there, so this is
the last but one level in the
last level it is filled from
left to right.
This is filled.
This is filled and then the next
thing can be here.
So this is the perfectly valid
complete binary tree.
Yes.
No, all of you convinced that is
why again kept on repeating
that.
Please watch recordings and
revise the concepts.
These two are perfectly valid
complete binary trees.
So till this last but one level,
they are fully filled in the
last level.
They are filled from left to
right.
Yeah.
So to be for all of you.
Yeah, everyone first property,
do both of them satisfy?
They are complete binary trees.
Now I'm going to do the next
check right?
66 is smaller than seven and six
is smaller than 12, so six is
smaller than both of its
children.
OK.
What about the next Level 7 is
smaller than 10 and seven is
smaller than 15.
OK.
12 is smaller than 17 and were
released.
There is no problem because
there is no children at all.
So for all internal nodes, if
you see that node value is
smaller than its children, so I
can tell that this is a min
heap.
What about the right side?
It is a complete binary tree.
OK, first property satisfied.
What about the second property?
17 is greater than its children,
15 and 10:15 is greater than its
children 6 and 10, and 10 is
greater than its child.
Seven.
And for leaves, there are no
children, so there is no
question of comparison.
So this is a Max heap.
Cool.
Let me know what do you think
about this one.
Is it a min heap or is it a Max
heap?
Or is it not a heap at all?
If it is not a heap, why is it
not a heap?
Yeah, I got the answers none.
Not a heap, not a heap.
Very good.
But why is it not a heap?
Very good.
Yeah, Vinay was bang on, he
told.
It's not even a complete binary
tree, right?
The very first step is whatever
tree is given.
You will check if it is a
complete binary tree or not.
In this case it is not.
Because of this, you know,
notorious guy, he's not as left
as possible.
He should have been the child
here, but he's somewhere here.
So this whole tree is not a
complete binary tree because it
is not a complete binary tree.
There is no way this can be a
heap.
Perfect.
What about this guy?
Easy.
Satisfying the shape property.
Still, here it is fully filled.
Here it is left as possible, so
this is a complete binary tree.
But what about the next step?
Let's inspect it.
Right, let's inspect it.
A couple of you are jumping the
bridge.
You're telling min heap and you
know that can deceive you.
It is not a heap actually, but
let's see one is smaller than
five and it is smaller than
seven.
OK, it is promising.
Maybe it looks like a min heap,
but I should check every node
like that.
Yeah, I should not jump the
bridge just by, you know,
looking at one or two values.
So one is smaller than five and
seven no problem.
But here, if you see five is
smaller than 10.
OK, very good.
But what about this five is not
smaller than four, so here there
is a problem coming up right
because of this problem.
This whole thing is not a heap
now.
Perfect.
Is everyone clear with what is a
heap now?
A heap is a special data
structure, a tree based data
structure which follows 2
properties, complete binary
tree.
That is the first property,
second property is the heap
property.
That is, it cannot be a mixture.
And so on.
It should either be a min heap
where every node is smaller than
its children, or it is a Max
heap where every node is greater
than its children or it is not a
heap at all.
Yeah, it is only min heap or Max
heap.
We cannot have a mixture of both
of them, like some parts are
Max.
Some parts are men that cannot
be there, yeah.
These are not heaps.
You can say it's complete binary
tree based data structure.
Yeah, exactly.
We can also say like that.
Yeah, well, deep representation.
How do you represent a heap if
you have listened to the last
classes carefully, you will
immediately answer this.
So what is a heap?
Heap is a complete binary tree,
right?
If it is a complete binary tree,
I will use an array.
Simple.
Yeah.
When all the elements are equal,
is it?
Yeah, you can call it either.
I mean heap or Max heap but but
as I told in most applications
of heap we will not be allowing
equal numbers, we will only have
distinct values.
But still with the definition
you can have some equals 2 S
that is still possible.
Yeah, but in that case it will
depend on the other nodes you
know, if it is, I mean heap or a
Max heap.
Since the heap is always a
complete, my retreat can be
represent a heap as a array
easily and effectively, yes?
So the exact same slide that we
had in the last class, whatever
we have, we will just, you know,
put the numbers 12345 and so on
from top to bottom left to
right.
I'll put it inside an array and
left for any node.
The left child will be in two I
position right child will be two
I plus one parent will be I by
two floor the exact same slide.
Yeah, so far, so good.
What all have you learned now if
a tree is given to you, will you
be able to recognize if it is a
heap or not?
So far it is fine.
We have not learned anything
complex like building a heap or,
you know, removing insertion and
all that.
But you know how to inspect what
is a heap or not?
Yeah, these all correlate to the
basic understanding of bloom
stacks onomy, meaning, you know
what is a heap?
You know the definition of it.
You know the property of it.
You know how to identify
something?
Ah, epoch, which is very
important.
Before we go further.
OK, let's have a look at this
example.
Interesting one and you will let
me know if this is a heap or not
real quick.
Yeah, real quick.
Not a heap.
If not heap, why is it violating
shape property?
Or is it violating keep
property?
Which property is it violating?
It is perfectly valid complete
binary tree, right?
Because until the last Butler
one level all are completely
filled.
Last level is from left to right
no problem.
So it is violating the heap
property which which guy is
violating.
Yeah, but before that, maybe
let's take a different route.
For now, let's just imagine the
left part of it right?
Maybe only the left part of it
that I've highlighted try to
only look at this and tell me if
this is a heap or not.
All of us agreed that the whole
tree was not a heap.
OK, fine.
I have now drawn something for
you.
I've highlighted something.
Is that a heap?
And if that is a heap, what type
of a heap is it?
Yes, it is a Max heap right 14
is greater than.
It's still run 10 and 12:10 is
greater than 7:00 and 9:12 is
greater than five and 11.
So this part of it is a Max
heap.
What about this right part?
He just focus on this one.
Is this a heap?
Eight is greater than four and
six, four is greater than three.
So this side also is a Max heap.
No problem.
All of these are fine, but who
played the spoilsport here?
The root this theory not obeyed.
If this was a 20 instead of A2.
If this was a 20 then I could
have called the whole tree as a
Max heap right?
So in this example, the left
side was also a Max heap.
Right side is also a Max heap,
whereas that one element
notorious element.
Because of that, this whole tree
is now not a heap.
Correct.
Is this part clear for everyone
and this notorious node could
have been anywhere?
Also, do you agree to that?
Also, it may not always been the
route it could have been
somewhere here.
It could have been somewhere
here or it can be anywhere in
the tree.
But even if there is one
violating node, then that is no
longer a heap, right?
So this is a common thing that
can happen, right?
So all of those are proper, but
there are certain nodes who are
violating and because of that
the whole tree becomes not a
heap.
This is this is just a normal
tree.
Now complete binary tree.
So in this cases, if they want
to make it a hit, what should I
do?
Yeah, one clever answer could be
that I will just replace the two
with, you know, some number.
So something like say 20 or 15
or something which is greater
than this 14 and eight so that
it becomes a heap but that is
not the right way.
So in this case, what we are
doing is we are actually
updating some value, right?
We are just manipulating the
node itself and then we are
claiming that this becomes a
keep.
We are not telling about that.
We are telling just with the
present elements, whatever is
there instead of updating or
changing the value, can we
rotate or move some things here
and there in order to make it a
heap?
Yeah.
Is that possible?
Yeah, NANDINI and others.
You in the right direction,
right?
We were discussing the methods
we looked at it, so in this
whole example we saw that you
know this part is a heap, right
side is also a heap, but there
was a problematic node.
So if I somehow move this or you
know do something, will I be
able to create a heap?
Let's look at it.
Compare this problematic node
with its children 14 and eight.
So who's the largest among them?
Yahoo's the largest 14.
14 So can I swap them if I swap
them like this 14 comes here and
two comes here.
So is it the top part now
satisfying 14 is greater than
two and eight?
No problem there is now.
If you see the below part here,
it is violating now right
because two is not greater than
its children 10 and 12 right?
Again same problem, but here it
was all good.
It is greater than four and six.
Four is greater than three no
problem, but in this part, after
this swap you have not fixed the
problem.
You have just postponed the
problem or you have pushed the
problem down.
Do you realize this?
All of you guys?
Yeah, it's very important.
You swapped the top level
because that was a problematic
node, and then after the swap
that became clear till here.
If you just observe 14 is
greater than its child two and
eight, it became a heap.
But you have actually not solved
the complete problem.
The problem has just been pushed
below.
If you see here, 2 is not
greater than 10 and 12.
Again, it is a violation, right?
So what should I be doing now?
Can I again take the maximum
value out of 210 and 12?
Who is largest?
A very good 12, so I will swap
these two people.
So now this will become 12 and
this will become two.
So now 12 is greater than 10 and
then you know 12 is greater than
two.
So till here it is perfect.
But now again there is a problem
here, right?
You have again pushed the
problem down, so I will take.
I'll compare these two with five
and 11.
So 11 is the greatest.
So I will again swap them so 11
will come here and two will come
here in that stage.
Can I call that whole tree to be
a heap?
Yes.
No, maybe.
More 11 to root?
No.
Why?
Why should I move to root and so
on?
No, that's it here.
I could have just stopped it,
yeah.
Who is this concept clear guys
for everyone? Yeah.
Do operation left tree and right
Tree as a.
So what does that do?
Operations or I didn't get that
part.
Yeah, all of you.
Let let me just repeat what we
just did.
There was a particular tree
given to us.
It was already a complete binary
tree and it was obeying some
sort of a Max heap, but there
were some node who was violating
that property and that node is
called as a problematic node and
we look at the problematic node
with its children and we try to
somehow swap it and we keep
doing that until the whole tree
becomes my desired heap.
Right.
This process is called as hippie
fication.
Yeah.
And now in this case, my desire
was to create a Max heap.
That is why I compared my two
with OT and eight and I took my
largest element at every swap.
I was taking the largest, so my
intention here was to create a
Max heap out of it, right?
So this whole process is then
called as Max EP 5.
Right.
If my intention was to create a
min heap, then I could have
compared and in every stage I
would have swapped it to the
minimum element, right?
And then at that time, I will
tell I'm doing min EPP file
right?
So these are all just umbrella
terms, but this whole concept is
called hippie fication, right?
I'll again repeat when there is
a tree given to you which is
already a complete binary tree,
but there are some nodes which
are problematic or meaning who
are violating the heap property.
And if you want to convert it
into a heap of your desired
form, right?
Maybe you want to create a Max
heap or you want to create a min
heap from that tree.
That process of somehow swapping
the elements and getting to the
desired heap is called heap
ification.
Is that clear?
All of you?
Yes, 2 and 14 that will not
solve the problem.
Again, you should do a swap.
That is what I was again
repeating.
Amit, 14, will come here.
Two will come here that will not
solve the problem.
Again, you will swap 2 and 12,
so two will come here.
Well, will come here.
That will also not solve the
problem, so again you will swap
this so this will become 11 and
this will become two and that
will solve the problem.
In that case, the whole tree
will look like a maxim, right?
So there are a lot of
misconceptions on these
terminologies, so let's be very
clear from not a heap to making
it a heap by this process of,
you know, again and again
swapping is called hippie
fication.
And if your aim is to create a
Max heap, then you apply
something called as Max CP5.
If you want to create a min
heap, you apply something called
as a min.
Heapify.
That's pretty much right.
Let's let's you know quickly.
Look at this. Yeah.
I have something even here.
It was the same note, so I just
swapped those two elements and I
made it something like this as
Amit and others.
All of you are telling the
problem is still not solved
right?
So I'll have to again compare
this and swap with the largest.
So two is compared with 10 and
12, so 12 was the largest.
So I'll swap 12 and two how it
became like this again, still it
is not a heap because the two is
not greater than five and 11.
So again, I will compare them
and I will swap them.
And now this tree is a maxim,
and in this whole problem my
focus was to create a maximum.
So the process that I've applied
here becomes Max.
CP5, let me now just take some
questions.
So Surendran had a question.
My assumption right?
Uh, if parent is problematic,
move the node downward and if
child is the problem, move
upward.
No, not at all.
Always the problem will be in an
internal node only, right?
A leaf node can never have a
problem because it doesn't have
a children's, so only the
internal nodes have a problem.
Problem.
So compare it with its children
and take the maximum and swap
it.
That's pretty much right.
There is no this shortcuts of
downward upward and so on.
This is the exact same process
that you have to follow.
Take the problematic node
wherever he is.
Compare it with its your
children, right?
Or one children wherever
possible, compare it with its
children and swap accordingly,
right.
If you are aim is to create a
Max heap, take the largest.
If your aim is to create a min
heap, take this smallest.
So what is the process we need
to follow when there is a
problem in more than one node?
This is exactly what we
followed, right.
You'll have two.
Let's take one problematic node
complete that whole thing, and
then go for another problematic
node.
And so on, right?
So what are?
Uh, So what do the numbers in
these nodes are?
They are just elements.
Yeah.
So they are say it is the roll
number of someone or marks of
someone.
It just like your presentation,
right?
Or it could be the agent,
whatever, right.
If one node is problematic, then
we can do typification of our N
or north number of nodes are
problematic.
Then we can do application.
Yeah, you can do for one also or
for north also, right.
So for one problematic node, if
you apply application on that
node, he will rectify that
whoever is their children, they
will get, you know keeping fried
or they will get, you know into
a heap.
But what if there were some
other problems here near 8 or
something?
Also, so I should have again
applied there.
Right.
Do we do if there is only one
bad node or even there?
Yeah, the same question we can
keep doing that in this example
22826 swap will be faster, but
yeah, we should not be doing all
that.
Yeah.
Again, this is the process.
That is, what is application and
we should not be resorting to
some other random swaps and one
yeah, you should start from the
problematic node.
Look at their children and do
the swap.
We should not restructure the
tree in some other, you know,
faster ways and so on, yeah.
The the IT will definitely
disturb the parent child
relationship.
What you will get will be a
completely different tree, but
that is what you intend to do,
right?
You intend to create a maxim,
then this is the only option,
but definitely you're right,
this swapping will cost certain.
You know, disruptions here,
right?
For example, here two was the
parent of 14, whereas at the end
of the day, if you see two and
14 are, you know not even you
know closely related that
becomes like the great
grandfather and so on.
But that's fine.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys?
For all of you, how do we decide
we need to do min heap or Max
separation?
That is, that will be known or
that is your decision.
Like what do you want?
If you want a Max heap, you will
do Max CP5.
If you want a min heap you will
do min heapify.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you?
We'll we'll proceed ahead.
I think most of the answers have
already.
You know, given right?
Yeah.
We will take some other
examples.
Yeah, but this is the code for
it.
Yeah, we will keep doing the,
you know such swaps.
So basically if majority of heap
notes no that it's not majority
and so on ways it it depends on
what you want.
I have a non heap.
Do I want a Max heap or do I
want a min heap?
Both are possible right at the
end of the day, it's all just
swaps.
So if you want a maxi, you will
apply Max CP5.
If you want a min heap, you will
apply min heapify right.
It's just a requirement based on
the requirement you will decide
what application to do right?
It is not based on the majority,
and so on.
Is it clear for all of you and
it just doesn't apply to
numerical?
It can be for characters also,
because at the end of the day
they are all, you know,
represented as number only,
right?
Puja, if you have a is nothing
but 65, right?
The ASCII value of it and askey
value can be used for that,
right?
Your name can be also be
translated into your askey or
unique code or whatever number,
and you can use that number or
directly.
Also you can apply right?
So how does this Max CP
algorithm look like?
This is exactly what we did now,
right?
Uh, so you have an input array
which is the representation of
that complete binary tree.
And yes, is an index of that
node.
Who?
What is a, you know?
Yes.
Can anyone take a guess what is
that?
Yes, node.
Yes, there's actually that
problematic note right.
And the results should be a heap
actually, right?
So what does that Max CP
algorithm?
It is that whole array
representation of that complete
binary tree and the problematic
node it left.
Tail will be in 2 S it's right,
tail will be in 2S plus one.
You do a simple if else
comparison this whole if else
lines.
You are doing to get to know who
is the largest, right?
That is what we have been doing
here.
We compared 214 and eight in
this case.
We compared 1210 and two.
Here we compared 11.
You know your 2511, you compare
them to find out the largest and
after this line you would have
had the largest element in your
largest variable.
Once you have that variable, if
that largest is not equal to
your position, in some cases it
might be right.
For example, I run this on 11/5,
two eleven is the largest and
that is where my mouth is
currently imagined.
Then I don't need to do any
swap, right?
But if that largest is not that
you know parent position, then
I'll have to swap that.
But that is not it.
Swapping one time will not do
the trick for me, because, as
you saw in this example, you
might have just pushed the
problem down, but you have not
fully solved it.
So what does this last line
again mean, and what does that
comment about this whole
algorithm?
Yeah, very good.
Yeah, it is a recursive
algorithm.
You're right.
After every swap, again we
should have Max CP5B comma
largest because in that position
I might have a problem again
like this and after this web
again on this we know tree I
should be running that algorithm
so that everything then becomes
a heap right?
So this particular algorithm
will take a problematic node and
it will ensure that anything
that is rooted on this node
right?
Anything below that?
Yes, all of them will become a
heap in this case.
I passed the essays this node.
Finally, it ensured that all of
them have become a heap, right?
If you had to write a min
heapify algorithm, what will
change in this?
Yeah.
How do we identify the
problematic uh node
programmatically?
Yeah, you should be comparing,
right?
The same first topic how will
you analyze if there is
something Max or min heap.
You will start comparing with
the children and you will get to
know that if who is violating
right.
That is why initially I asked
you before proceeding.
Do you now know how to check if
something is a hip or not right
that first node who is violating
will become your problematic
node.
Yeah, very good, all of you.
So instead of these largest you
will have a smallest variable
and here you will have a check
where instead of largest element
you will use the lesser than
symbol right in code how will we
check for uh brute yeah.
The first node is always the
root. Guys.
Come on.
Yeah.
Please go through the notebooks.
Yeah.
So always the first element is
the root, right?
Is it correct all of you when
you translate?
Your array like this 25 is
always the first element and
that is the route right?
It's all very simple stuff.
Cool.
The time complexity of Max CP5IS
log N why is it log in?
Yeah.
Think this is a binary tree or a
complete binary tree?
Maximum how much can a node get
swapped?
Any ideas?
Let's say suppose I have the
root element as the problematic
node, right?
This node, how much can he get
swapped?
Yeah, from root he can get
swapped until leaf right he in
this case from 14 he came here.
But again two was a problem.
We go to app again.
There's a problem.
He got swapped so that swap can
happen from top till it can
happen until the root level also
from the leaf level also which
is nothing but the height of the
tree right from top level.
Every stage there is some swaps
that is happening.
So what is the height of a
complete binary tree?
Yeah.
What is the height of a complete
binary tree?
It is nothing but log in right?
We learned it in the last class.
So what happens is since the
complete binary tree is
perfectly balanced, shifting up
a single node takes log N time,
right?
Maximum log in only.
It can swap.
It cannot go and swaps and so
on.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you?
Yes.
No, maybe.
So what all do we know now?
I'll keep asking if a tree is
given.
Do we know how to check if it is
a heap or not?
We will check if it is CBT or
not.
We'll also see if it is Max CP
or min heap.
If it is not, then it is not a
heap at all that we know, and
then we also saw that something
is a CPT, but it is not a heap,
some some problematic nodes are
there right?
Then how do I convert it?
It's your requirement.
If I want a Max heap, I will
apply Max CP5.
If you want a min heap, I will
apply min heap 5 and what are
these two?
What is this whole technique
called and someone reply on
that?
What is this Max CP5 meaning P5
etcetera.
And then they're all swaps.
Technically they are just swaps,
but this whole concept is called
hippie fication, meaning
converting a non heap into heap
right?
That is called help if you right
Max CP5.
If you do, you will get maxi min
he P5P you do, you'll get min
heap the whole point there is
you are just, you know, checking
at every stage comparing.
If you know you want to Max, you
will choose the largest and
swap.
If you are performing min heap,
you will choose the min and swap
right.
As simple as that, but so far
have we learned about how to
build a heap or how to insert a
heap?
How to remove from a heap all
those have you learned?
Not yet.
So that is what we will learn
now.
Building a heap can be done in
two ways.
OK, don't get confused.
You can do building a heap in
two ways.
We will learn both the
techniques.
The first technique is using
this typification itself keep
building can be done effectively
using bottom up fashion given an
arbitrary complete binary tree,
we can assume each leaf is a
heap.
Yeah, this line is there any
confusion so the whole heap
property or heap concept
revolves around this parent and
child right the parent if it is
greater than child then it is
Maxim.
If the parent is smaller than
leap or children, then it is min
heap.
But for leaf nodes, there is no
children at all.
Then can I assume that all the
leaves are already heaps?
Yeah.
Can someone tell me that and
making a claim that all the
leaves are already heaps?
For example, this 79523.
The six there's no problem with
it because it doesn't have a
child at all.
If there is no child, then there
is no question of you know, it
being greater than the child or
it being lesser than the child.
There is no question at all, so
I can very clearly comment that
all these leaf nodes are already
heaps, right?
So where can a problem happen?
Can a problem happen on a leaf
node or can it happen on an
internal node?
If at all something is
violating, yeah, it need not be
root, it can be here also,
right?
In this case, it violated here.
In this case, it violated here,
right?
So the violation might happen
only in the internal node and of
course root is also an internal
node, but an eleaf there cannot
be any problem.
So now if we proceed ahead with
this definitions, given an
arbitrary complete binary tree.
We assume each leaf is a heap,
no problem.
Start building the heap from the
parents of these leaves, meaning
internal notes, right, Max
Heapify the subtrees rooted at
the parent.
If you apply Max CPU, what will
the be the result you will get?
What type of a heap you will
get?
You'll get a maximum because you
are applying Max CP5, but if you
wanted them in heap you can
apply min heapify.
I have not given that version of
Min Heapify which is exactly
opposite where you will take the
minimum of them right.
The hippie process continues
till we reach the root of the
tree.
Let's firstly take this
particular.
Example.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yes.
No.
Maybe it's a complete binary, no
problem.
Is this a heap or not?
Two is smaller than five and six
no.
Problem 5 is smaller than nine
and seven, right?
So what type of a heap is this?
It is a min heap.
Perfect.
Cool.
Let's assume this was not a
heap.
Also, right in that case also
these leaves are not a problem.
The problem could have been
somewhere here in the internal
node only, right?
So this whole algorithm tells me
that don't worry about the leaf
leaves are going to be always
heap start from the internal
node and perform hyperfixation
right perform hyperfixation.
For example, I want a maximum
this this is a Max heap.
Yes.
No, maybe.
This is not a maximum, but let's
say I wanted a maxim this is not
a maxi, so I should perform
hippie fication in order to get
the maximum.
How do I do that?
This algorithm says start
building the heat from the
parents of these sleeves.
Now, is there any formula to
give me where are internal nodes
and where are lead so far have
we learned about such concepts?
Yeah.
Yeah, Please wait.
Yeah, don't swap it immediately.
We should take it very step by
step.
Given a complete binary tree, is
there any formula that can tell
me who are all the leaf nodes
and who are all internal nodes?
Yeah.
Yes, there is formula and
putting numbers as usual 12345
right?
4 leaf left, right, or uh null.
Beautiful.
That's one way to identify it,
but are there formulas without
traversing the tree?
Can I write away tell you that
these nodes are internal?
These nodes are external, but is
also possible that is the whole
beauty of computing right.
Simran sensor was right but that
is for that you have to traverse
the tree and you should see if
the nodes left and right part
are null.
Then you can claim that that is
a diff.
Otherwise it is an internal
node, but in that case you'll
have to traverse it, but without
all that.
Definitely I can do using these
two formula.
What does this say?
All leaf nodes are from north by
two floor value plus one to N
these positions will be a leaf
node and all non leaf nodes,
meaning internal nodes are from
one to north by two floor value.
Let's put this into practice.
Let's see if I'm lying.
Or are these formulas actually
working?
So in my case, what is yen in
this example?
Real quick? Yeah.
What is my yen?
Yen is nothing but number of
nodes.
How many nodes are here?
5 nodes are there right?
So what did this line tell me?
All leaf nodes are from north by
2 + 1, which is nothing but five
by two floor value plus one to
end which is 5.
What is 5 by two?
Five by two is 2.52 point, five
floor values 2/2 plus one is 3,
so three to five.
So this formula tells me that
three to five those nodes are
leaf nodes is what this tells
me?
Let me go check it in the tree.
What about the third position?
It is a leaf.
What about the fourth position?
It is a leaf.
Fifth position is also a leaf.
What about this formula?
This formula told me all non
leaf nodes or internal nodes are
from one to north by 2412 N by
two floor value is nothing but
12 N is nothing but five, five
by two floor value is 2 to one
to two is internal node is what
it tells me.
So one if I look yes, it is an
internal node because it has
children.
Two is also an internal node
because it has children.
So are these two formulas
working not just for this tree,
for any complete binary tree,
this formula will work, yeah.
And these type of detections is
what is expected from you.
Yeah, and quizzes and exams.
I might come up with some crazy,
you know, statements you should
think about it and come up with
such formulas.
Yeah, just by trial and error.
Also, you can actually figure
out these formulas.
Yeah, well, now we understood
the formulas of in what
positions leaves are there and
in what positions internal nodes
are there.
Yeah.
Second one, will you explain
once again what is the second
one?
Very simple 12 N by two, floor
value 125 by two floor value 125
by two is nothing but 2.52 point
five floor values 2 right.
So one to two, meaning one and
two, right?
So the formula says in one and
two positions there are non leaf
nodes, so the first position.
If you say yes, it is non non
leaf node, it has children.
What about second position?
Yes, it has children, so it is
correct.
The both the formulas are
correct and they give me in a
complete binary tree which
positions are leaf and which
positions are internal node.
So far so good.
All of you, Amit.
It just it just giving me
positions where internal node
and leaf nodes are there.
Now we did all this homework
because whatever positions this
sensor gives me, I don't need to
worry at all because they're all
leaf nodes.
Leaf nodes are already heaps.
I don't need to worry at all,
whereas all these positions
which this formula gives me
right in this case there can be
a problem.
So I will start heapy flying in
those positions, meaning in this
second position and in this
first position I'll perform my
EP fication whatever I want,
right.
If the statement is true, can we
say it's uh CBD?
Uh.
True.
No, no, you should not reverse.
Uh, you know, tell that if it's
a CPT then these formulas will
work.
Just because these formulas
work, I should not claim that it
is a CBT, yeah.
Cool.
Have a look at the small
algorithm to build a heap now
using all these concepts that we
learned.
Yeah.
If you look at this, P is an
input array.
This input array is nothing but
that complete binary tree that
I've got.
The result should be a heap.
Can I just simply tell that the
size of my heap will be the size
of this array?
Yes, of course.
Right.
I'm just exchanging the things
I'm not going to add any new
element, so the length of this
complete binary tree is going to
be the length of my heap, and
then what I do is this.
Same formula I'm doing it in the
reverse right instead of from
going from one to north by two
floor value.
I'm going from north by two
floor value till one.
And what I'm doing I'm
performing Max Heapify on each
of that is nothing but that
variable right.
In this example, I will first
take this second position, then
go to that first position.
I'll start applying my Max CP5
eventually.
This complete thing will become
a heap.
Let's take another example.
Let's take this.
I have this Ariel representation
I've converted into a complete
binary tree.
This is now a complete binary
tree and I wanted a maxiprep.
Is this a Maxey?
Real quick guys, so we get a CT
and make it a heap.
Exactly.
Yeah, if it is not a complete
binary tree then you cannot do
anything and you should not do
anything right.
You should not apply these
techniques and try to create a
heap and all that.
You should right away tell that
you know what this is.
Not even satisfying the shape
property, so this is not a heap.
If it is satisfying the shape
property, if it violates the
heap property, then I can build
my heap using this technique.
In this case, I was given a list
of numbers and I just translated
into a complete binary tree,
right?
So the order of this algorithm
is N log in.
We will come there.
Yeah, we'll come there.
Let's quickly finish this part
and this is not my Max heap.
What did my algorithm say?
All the leaf nodes don't worry
about it.
Start with the first non leaf
node.
What are all the non leaf nodes?
This five is an odd leaf.
Four is an on Leaf, three is an
on leaf, two is a non leaf, one
is a non leaf, meaning they all
have children right 4567.
No, that is wrong.
Non leaf guys.
Yeah, 54321 because they have
children 678910 R not having any
children.
You could have even applied that
formula here.
Yeah, that formula if you apply
12 N by two floor value will be
internal node.
In this case it is 1010 by two
is 5.
So it told you that 12345
positions are internal, 678910
are leaf.
So I start from this position
and I will apply Max CP5 there.
So what will happen?
I'll compare 5 and 10/5 is not
greater than 10.
So what should happen?
You'll get swapped.
It will become like this and
then I will go to the next
internal node.
I will go to this position.
Fourth position.
I'll compare 48 and 9, which is
the largest 9 is the largest, so
I'll swap it so it'll get
swapped and nine will go there.
So are you slowly understanding
what we are doing?
All the leaps were already
heaps, leaves, and then we
started with the last internal
node.
This part became a heap right 10
is greater than five Max heap
and then we compared here, nine
was greater than four and eight.
So that became the, you know
parent here.
So now this whole portion is
also a heap and is greater than
five.
Nine is greater than the
children eight and four.
This full is done.
Next we will consider here this
position said, why didn't we
start with four?
Why only 5?
Because that is the last
internal node.
What did this formula tell me
from B dot length divided by two
down to one, meaning the last
internal node who's that?
Yeah.
OK, that's fine.
If you understood the concept,
if you have not understood the
formulas, it's fine.
Yeah, you will rewatch the
recording.
It'll strike you why we use the
formula, but a simpler way is if
you have understood the concept
from the last internal node
right.
In this case one is internal
node, two is internal, node
three is internal, node four is
internal node.
This five is internal node, so
this is the last internal node
right after that the six is the
leaf, 7 is a leaf 8910, they're
all leaf.
So this last internal node you
picked up, you performed
hyperfixation on that first and
then you went to the second last
internal node.
Who was that?
This for so this whole position
also you applied Max CP5 this
also became a heap who is the
next internal node this three so
367 are compared seven is the
largest.
So you will swap them and that
will become.
This whole part also now became
a heap.
Who's the next internal node?
This too.
So you will compare them so 2910
you will compare who's the
largest, 10 is the largest, so
you'll swap it.
But after that swap what will
happen?
Yeah, 10 would have come here to
would have come here.
This part would have become a
heap, but two is here, but two
is not.
You know greater than five, but
you know what is Max CP5, Max.
CP5 is a recursive algorithm, so
he would have internally swapped
him and it would have already
converted him something like
this, right.
You understood, right.
So 10 would have come here.
Two would have come here.
We will not a heap again because
this part is violating.
So, since Max CP5 itself is
recursive again, we swapped and
it became like this.
Now again, let's recap.
This is a heap.
This whole part is a heap.
The 763 is a heap this whole 10
and it's children is a heap,
right?
All the internal nodes.
Now we will finally go to that
last internal node which was
root 1071.
We will swap 10 right and then
one would have come here again.
This is not a heap, so nine
would have come one here and so
on.
And finally would have got a
tree like this which is a Max
heap.
Yeah, the original Teresa mean
in this case, occasionally it
happened to be Amandeep, but it
could have been just a normal
tree also, right, Manish?
And Max application is done.
Yeah.
I mean the whole algorithm is
over.
You have built a heap now.
Yeah.
And somewhere I saw beautiful
answer.
I think it was Vinay when I told
that we are considering each non
leaf is problematic heap and
applying the typification
algorithm beautiful.
That's the exact concept here,
yeah.
Yeah, we can.
We should not call this sorting
and so on.
This is not sorting.
This is CP fication.
In what sense is it sorting?
Are we sorting something here?
No, we are not starting
anything.
We are swapping swapping based
on some concepts, right?
It's snow is building the heap
clear, and in this case I wanted
a Max heap so at every stage I
applied Max CP5.
But if I wanted min heap, I
would have applied min heap
fine.
Yeah.
Which part is not clear.
How quickly recap?
Let's not revolve too much
around this.
It's a very simple concept.
There's an array given to you.
You translated into a complete
binary tree.
So far so good.
All of you.
Don't worry about what this is.
This is.
I mean, he maxim, don't worry
about it.
It can be anything.
It may not be a heap at all
also, but whatever was given you
translated into a complete
binary tree in that every non
leaf node, or in other words
every internal node, you will
consider it and you will apply
the Max CP5 or min he P5AS per
what you want.
In this case I want to have a
final Max heap.
So on all the internal nodes I
will apply Max CP5, but there is
a simple trick that start from
the last internal node.
So in this case, if you see five
is the last internal node,
right?
Because six is a LEAF, 7 is a
leaf, 8910 are all Leafs, so
this last internal node start
from here.
Apply Max CP5 here.
So this part will become a heap,
then go to its previous internal
node.
This part again apply Max CP5.
This will become a heap.
Then this whole 3 then this two
and whole.
You know, people will become
complete by tree, will become a
heap.
It will become Max CP5 because I
applied Max CP Fication.
Yeah.
Is this part clear?
And then he now and again urge
you to try some numbers like
this random numbers try to
create.
Of course, there are a lot of
exercises in this deck.
You will get a better hang of
it, but what you are essentially
trying to do is you are
repeatedly applying Max CP5 or
min PY as per what you want on
all the internal nodes.
This.
Sir, we are saying that leaf is
not considered as non
problematic as we do swap two
and five and one and eight.
Yeah, leaf was not problematic
there also it was this internal
node who was problematic.
This tool was problematic.
This five was not problematic,
yeah, said why 3 is not swapped
with four?
So where exactly?
So in which step do you mean?
Yeah.
So they're completely different,
right?
So seven is greater than six and
three there ends the matter.
This is already a Max sleep.
Yeah, why should I be swapping 2
four and others?
They are in some other place.
Five is greater than two.
Eight is greater than four, so
there in the matter I should not
be swapping between them and so
on.
They are building analysis,
right?
Someone we're already telling
Jagdish and others right, we are
calling Max CP5 on north by two
nodes, right.
As leaves are already ahead,
since we call Max CP5N times and
Max CP5 takes log N time, the
overall complexity is N log N.
Yeah, in this case, the overall
complexity to build a heap bus
and log N, whereas this is not
tight, we can also prove that
building a heap is not N log N
it is just we go off and also
yeah, for what concept is this?
If you are telling not tight and
if you are trying to get an even
tighter complexity, there is
some analysis for this.
Yeah.
And that is what we started the
whole class today with.
Yeah, what concept is that?
Is it worst case analysis or
something else?
We did the worst case analysis.
We got it as N log N nobody can
tell N log N is wrong that is
fine.
But it is not as tight.
We can also prove that it is
just we go of EN so very good
that's called amortized
analysis, right?
So the whole proof is also
available in your clears
textbook.
It's available if you are
interested.
You can also have a look at it,
but the bottom line is creating
a heat using this technique.
This technique is called as he
application technique right
using the hippie fication
technique.
If you build a heap, the
complexity is big of north.
Sir parent is 10, left child is
9, right child is 8.
Is it possible?
Yes, of course it is possible.
If that is the case, then what
is the, you know heap name?
This is 10 left child is 9 by
child is 8.
So what type of heap is this?
Again, Please remember there is
no relation between left child
right child, only parent child
is coming into picture.
Yeah, there is no relation
between left or right.
They can be anything as long as
this 10 is greater than nine and
eight.
I can just simply call it as a
maxi.
That's all.
There is no relation between
them.
Children are not related.
Falling Maxi pen by two times.
Yes.
Correct, because there are N by
two internal nodes.
Krishna right now is when if you
go to the code again, if you see
here N by two times this loop is
running.
So north by two times you are
calling this Max CP5.
This line is going to take you
log in and this line is taking
you N by two, who is a constant,
so this is yen.
So if you see end into log N is
N log N that is the correct
answer if you do normal
analysis.
But if you do amortized
analysis, you will know that it
is not N log N.
You can also very well claim it
as we go N itself.
All that being said, let's take
a very quick break and then we
will come back with insertion
and deletion.
Yeah, we'll come back in 5
minutes.
Not more than that, and I'll
still be around if you have any
other general questions or
something we can chat about it.
Internal nodes are five by two.
Yes, correct five by two.
Floor value 5 by two floor
values 2.5 floor value which is
2.
So there are only two internal
nodes in that example.
In this example, there are only
two internal nodes.
What about in this example?
And this 1010 by two floor
values, it is five floor value
which is 5.
So this formula claims there are
five internal nodes.
Is that clear internal node,
internal node?
Internal node, internal node,
internal.
Everything else is a leaf, so
how many on how many nodes you
applied?
Max CP5 in this slide.
If you clearly observe that we
had done actually five times.
Right.
This was the first time this was
the second time this was the
third time.
This was the 4th time but fourth
time actually internally it had
two again do the Max CP file
algorithm did it again should
not count that finally fifth
time we did yeah starting of the
class I briefed that.
Yeah, I told about amortized.
Please watch the recording
again.
Yeah, but they are a little
slightly advanced concepts.
There was also a webinar on
that.
Please watch that recording and
also there is this whole proof
in your text.
Also, they're they're not be
much questions and so on from
your exam point of view because
it's not very clearly there in
your course.
Uh, 111 question, just to be
sure, no Python code is asked in
Midsem and compare exam, right?
Correct.
That's right.
If you write a Python code for
some answer, it will not be even
looked it and it'll be straight
given a zero.
Yeah, in the return exam, it
will always be a suedo code or
an algorithm.
Only in your assignment you will
write Python code, but a lot of
people will end up writing some
code and we will not consider
code.
The question will clearly tell.
Write an algorithm or write a
pseudo code a niece.
See Language, Java, Python,
etcetera.
You should not be writing in the
exam.
So internal node order will be
UH-5423.
Uh, so in which examples will be
you mean this example?
Internal node.
The order will be in the
reverse, just the normal
reverse, so you will go to 5th
node, then to 4th, then to 3rd,
then to, then to one.
There's the reverse order.
Yeah, and not 5423, yeah.
Difference between regular and
makeup exam?
Yeah.
So the regular is the actual
exam day and for people who
might not be able to attend that
day, right for someone might say
I have an important meeting that
day and traveling abroad or so
there was some case I still
remember and they told I have my
marriage on my regular exam day.
So what do you expect me to do?
Right.
For such cases, you already know
the regular exam date and if on
that day if you have any
important commitment which you
cannot skip, you will be given a
chance to write the makeup exam,
yeah.
For particular height of CBT
Max, how many times at worst we
can swap to build a heap?
Or do we have any formula?
Yeah, that's log north, right
maximum.
Someone who is at the top can
give or can go all the way up to
a leaf.
It cannot go below that correct.
So anyone who's at the top, he
can keep on getting swapped.
He can go all the way till the
bottom and that is nothing but
the height of a complete binary
tree which is always log.
Do we need to give application
for backup exam day?
Sir, no, you need not.
There will be a hall ticket
generation day when if you know
that on that regular day you are
not available, you will choose
the makeup exam date that time
itself.
Yeah, there is no other separate
application and so on.
3rd uh, so we should remember
algorithms with respect to exam
point of view, right?
Yeah, not just exam point of
view.
You should remember it
holistically.
I mean, even after exams, we
should remember them, right in
terms of height.
Do we have any formula?
Yeah, log in itself is the
formula.
The height of a complete binary
tree is log N simple.
We'll we'll wait for another
minute and then we will get
started.
Wow.
Yeah, we will come there.
Yeah, you'd be welcome there.
There are several applications
of heaps, yeah, the whole heap
sort is based on heap.
Yeah, very popular sorting
algorithm and there are other
bigger applications which we
will look at in the next class.
Since Max CP method under for
loop is calling only once not
traverse thought out till leave
so uh because yeah that could be
1 probable way.
But that Max CP5 method itself
is a recursive algorithm.
You realize that, right, Vinay?
It'll ensure that whatever is
the problem is again recurring.
He will solve that also in this
case.
It had happened right?
10 and two had got swapped, but
again this part became not a
heap.
So here I ensured that is also
getting swapped Max CP file.
Algorithm itself is recursive in
nature.
It was iterating it thing
NANDINI had pointed out long
back.
That last line, right.
Oops.
Got this lane right?
So if you see the last line is
again recursive, so he will
ensure that.
For whatever significance of
webinars or the vinas topics.
So for umm yeah it it will be
there for exams.
Yeah, they're basically some
topics which are not directly
taught in the class, but related
to the course.
All the topics covered in
webinar are also there in the
course, meaning you can there
might or might not be questions
from you know those also in the
exam who should prepare that
also.
So if it's a perfect penetrate,
yeah, you can actually apply.
Yeah, but but the definitions is
it should be a complete binary.
That is good enough.
You need not wait for a perfect
binary tree.
Which is a complete binary
that's good enough.
There are no code in DSD. Only.
Yeah, I'm talking only about
Syed.
Yeah.
So don't take my word for other
courses, only for DSAD.
Whatever I tell applies, yeah.
Cool.
I think it's and UH-49.
Let's get started.
Yeah.
So building a heap, all of you
clear? Yeah.
So all of you will now answer a
couple of things.
If a tree is given, will you be
able to identify if it is a heap
or not?
If it is a Max heap min heap,
not a heap, will you be able to
do that?
Yeah.
Perfect.
That is one step.
Then, if there is a complete
monetary given to you, but with
some random numbers, it's not a
min heap, it's not a Max heap,
but I tell you, go ahead and
create a min heap out of this.
Will you be able to do that?
Yeah.
What is it that you will do?
You will start SURBHI.
Yeah, you will start from the
last internal node.
You will go all the way till the
root right?
Basically, in all the internal
nodes you will perform min
heapify because you wanted I
mean heap.
If you want a Max heap, you will
apply min heapify on all those
internal nodes.
If you do it magically, what you
will get is a heap.
Is that clear?
So far, so you know how to
check.
You know also how to build right
now let's assume you have built
a heap.
You have built a Max heap.
You want to insert something in
it?
Yeah.
How do you do that simple step?
If you are inserting something
in a Max heap after the
insertion, also it should be a
Max heap.
Yeah.
Beautiful, right?
Your insertion should not spoil
the whole thing.
Understood.
Right, you have a Max heap.
You insert it after the
insertion.
Also it's a Max heap.
It's a min heap.
You insert some number after
that.
Also, it should be a min heap,
so that is your responsibility
to insert it in such a way or
take care of it.
So what are the steps testing?
First find the insertion point Z
meaning in this particular tree.
So what type of a heap is this?
Or is it not a heap 2 smaller
than five and six five smaller
than nine and seven?
So this is a what type of a heap
place.
I mean, he perfect.
So after I insert also it should
be a min heap.
Yeah.
So what is the analysis?
Yeah, Krishna, I didn't do any
analysis.
I just told before starting if
it's a min heap after inserting
also it should be a min heap.
If it is a Max seep after
insertion also it should be a
Max heap.
Simple.
Yeah.
So in this case I have a min
heap I want to insert an
element.
But firstly, can I just insert
it anywhere I like?
Can I insert it to the left of 6
right of 6 left of nine right of
nine?
Can insert it anywhere?
Or is there a specific position?
Yeah.
What is this position in this
example?
If I insert it to the left of
nine or right of nine or left of
seven or right of seven, it will
make the whole thing as a, not a
complete binary tree.
Then one move will completely
spoil this foot, right?
It will not be a heap at all
then, so the only possible thing
is the left of six.
Yeah, not nine also, Amit, if
you do in the left of nine, then
the whole thing is not a
complete binary tree at all.
Then there is no question of
equal also, right?
So the only possible thing is
the left of six.
Then it will be a CBT, so that
position is called AZ yeah, find
the insertion point Z so that we
maintain complete binary tree
property.
Perfect.
You will find it out.
You will insert it, but after
inserting it might have violated
the heap property.
It can happen.
Check if the heap property
follows.
If it is not following, restore
the heap property by using up
heap bubbling.
Yeah.
Let's see that insert the
element one into the min heap.
Let's do that.
This was the min heap given to
me.
I know this is my insertion
point, ZI inserted him, my
insertion is over now.
Is this a min heap?
Yeah, exactly.
Don't break the CPT after that.
Is it a heap 6 is greater than
one?
But then how is this?
I mean heap.
So he did his, you know, game.
Now this is not even a heap, So
what should I be doing?
As usual, I should swap.
I will compare one and six right
one is smaller, so swap him.
Compared swapped again, compare
two and one right.
So two and one again two is
greater than one.
So that's a problem.
So so up him.
And now in this case is this a
heap min heap?
One is smaller than five and
two, five is smaller than nine
and seven.
Two is smaller than six, so this
is now what min heap.
So before insertion it was a min
heap after insertion.
Also it is a min heap so you are
done and this whole concept if
you see here you are always
inserting somewhere at the
bottom.
Do you agree to it?
You cannot insert it at the root
or middle or somewhere right?
Somewhere at the bottom is what
you're inserting, and that guy
is bubbling up, so there's one
got swapped here.
He went here and he got, you
know, swapped here again.
And he went on to the top.
Why didn't we check for file?
We checked it, but it was
already correct, right?
Five is smaller than nine and
seven, so no problem, right?
So that is why that name is
called up heap bubbling.
So after you insert something at
the bottom, if he violates the
property he made bubble up and
he will go to his proper
position.
That is why this concept is
called up heat bubbling.
So again, I repeat, these are
all just antsy jargons, but what
exactly is this API bubbling?
Can someone answer me in layman
terms?
What do you mean actually in
operation computing terms?
What is that?
You can inserted something here.
It violated the property, so I'm
just telling this jargon that
I'm bubbling up.
So what do you actually mean by
that?
No, not bottom up. Swapping.
Yeah, that is the right word.
I'm just doing swaps.
I'm just doing swap in order to
get it to the proper place, or
in other words he, P cation or
whatever you can call, but the
actual word in literature is
upbeat.
Bubbling.
Yeah, that's right.
Soumya you do the insertion and
then you but that is what you
should not call it as Max CP5
mean P5 etcetera.
You should call it as perform up
heap bubbling.
Meaning you insert it and then
it bubbles up to his proper
position.
Yeah, it works like bubble sort
in some sense.
Yeah, it goes through its proper
position, but all these concepts
are actually the same. Correct?
Swapping heapify acation up,
heap bubbling, they're all
actually nothing, but just
normal swap, with the intention
of what I want, yeah.
We should not do Max. Min heap.
Yeah, that is what, again, I
repeat, yeah, or in them, if it
is a min heap after the
insertion, it should be a min
heap.
So you will perform API bubbling
in such a way that you will
maintain the min heap property.
Otherwise, if it is a maxim
already after insertion also it
should be maximum.
So let's quickly go through this
slide.
After the insertion of the new
element, the heap order property
may be violated at times.
It may not violate also correct
and then apply.
Bubbling restores the heap
property.
Compare and swap eh upward the
path and it can bubble up until
two things can happen.
Either it can bubble up all the
way till the root or somewhere
in the middle itself.
The heap property can be
satisfied and if it is satisfied
I can stop there.
So in worst case what can
happen?
Whatever inserted at the bottom
can bubble up all the way till
the root, which means it is the
height of the tree and height of
the tree is nothing but log in.
So the complexities log in Sir.
This min or Max heap only
possible in CBT.
Yes, that is what we learned in
the very first slide.
Yeah, again, repeat, please
focus 200% because this is the
pedagogy we use in this class.
I keep repeating and going fast,
so please focus.
Yeah.
The very first slide was about
the ship property, so if it is
not a CBT, it's not a heap at
all.
Yeah, yeah, keep bubbling can be
returned.
Both respective of min and heap
correct.
It depends on what you want.
If it's a min heap, you will do
a pip bubbling in such a way
that you are swapping the
smaller term.
It's Max heap.
You will swap with the larger
term insertion.
All of you clear?
Yes.
No, maybe.
There is already a heap given to
you.
You will insert it.
You will adhere to this up heap
public.
What about removal in the stack,
which is the only element that I
can remove?
Yeah, example is what we just
saw, right.
There was an element I inserted
one after I inserted one, it is
no longer a min heap, so he got
swapped.
He again got swapped and then
what?
I got as a result is a mean heap
cool.
Very good.
So what we learned is in a stack
only top element can be removed
in a queue.
What is the only element that we
can remove?
Can it randomly remove
something?
The element given in the front
front position only I can remove
right?
Not leave only the one who's
given by the front full.
Similarly, in a heap, right, I
can only remove the route.
Don't ask me why, because that
is by nature.
That is by design.
You cannot remove any element
that you like.
You can only remove the root
element.
Remove the element at the root
node.
But if you remove the root
element, what will happen to the
whole tree right?
For example, there is a tree
like this, you just knock off
this whole route.
Then it will not be a tree at
all.
This whole thing becomes
disconnected.
Will become an orphan, right?
There should be something to
keep this intact, right?
So what I'm going to do?
Yeah, I am going to take the
last leaf and put him there.
Yeah, remove the element at the
root node from the heap, fill
the root node with the element
from the last node, right so
that you maintain the complete
binary tree property.
Otherwise, all of you are right,
it will get broken.
It'll get disjoined it will
become a forest.
All that is correct, but I don't
want that to happen, right?
I want it to still remain as a
complete mandatory.
I want to make it still a heap,
so take the last node and put
him there right after doing
that, it'll become a complete
binary tree, correct?
But it might violate the
property, so check if the he
follows the heap order property.
If it doesn't follow, perform
the downhead bubbling.
Very simple steps guys.
Don't get confused.
Always the only element you can
remove from a heap is the root.
You knock him off once you knock
him off, the whole tree becomes
an orphan because there is no
root now.
So take the last element,
meaning the last leaf.
Put him in that position of the
root the moment you do that, it
will now become a complete
binary tree.
Now check if that is a heap or
not 2 accordingly and that is
called as down heap bubbling.
We look at an example, it will
be clear perform a delete
operation on the given min heap,
perform a delete operation.
I have not told which node to
delete because it's understood
that I can only delete the
route.
So in this case, what will I
delete?
Who will be removed?
But after two is removed, what
will happen?
The whole tree will get
disconnected.
So which node should I be
putting there?
If you put a number, this is
12345.
The last node, which is 7 that
node I'll put him there.
Something like this?
Two will be deleted and replaced
with seven.
Perfect.
Yeah.
So I have done that after doing
that.
This is also a complete binary
tree, so no harm to that
complete binary property
satisfied now.
Is this still a min heap 7 is
greater than five and six?
Oops, there's a problem right.
Initially what I had is A2
smaller than 565, smaller than
97.
It is a min heap, so after
removal also it should be a min
heap whereas here after that
removal and after this 7 going
up this has become a not a min
heap.
So there's a problem.
So what should I be doing?
Yeah, seven should be compared
with five and six.
The minimum value is 5, so I
will take him there, right?
I took him there and now five is
smaller than seven and six.
Seven is smaller than 9, so I
can stop there itself, right?
I have skin.
Stop him.
And here if you understand what
happened, the top node is
bubbling down right?
The seven bubble down to its
proper position here.
That is why this concept is
called down heap bubbling right?
So all of you have understood
it, but some people are telling
hippie fication and all that we
should not use such terms
because he pacification is a
concept to transform a non heap
into a heap.
So that is where you should use
that word.
And here the right word is what
Simmental, don't he bubbling
after the last node end on top?
It is bubbling down to its
proper position by using compare
and swap.
How long can this round heap
bubbling happen?
In this example, this seven
bubble down to here and then
here itself.
I stopped it because if I here
itself, it satisfied the min
heap 5 is smaller than 706 and
seven is smaller than nine.
So here itself I will stop.
This can happen or in worst case
what can happen.
It can go all the way till the
least this seven, which was a
root can go all the way till the
leaf.
What is the worst case and in
that case, what is the, you know
number of swaps done, which is
the height of it, which is
nothing but log this exact same
slide?
That is what it says that you
know after replacing the node,
fill it with the last node and
it might violate the heap
properties.
So you know, go ahead and swap
it.
It can either go all the way
till I leave or it can.
You can stop it where it's
satisfied.
If it goes all the way till the
leaf, which is worst case, it
would have performed swapping
login times.
So the complexity is logged.
Cool excise this time.
Yeah, there's a lot of exercises
for you.
So Sir, compare and swap should
only happen on the branches that
got affected.
We don't need to compare other
branches, is that correct?
That's right, only in that path
you should be doing it.
Yeah, I went to the last slide,
Ruby.
Yeah, you should be 200% alert
for 120 minutes and then that's
fine, yeah.
One more.
OK, here.
So seven got compared with this
five and six, right.
The last two trees.
Yeah, I'll come there.
So seven got compared with five
and six, which is the smallest
among them.
Five.
So five got swapped with seven,
right?
That is what we are indicating.
So five got swapped here and
after this if I inspect this
guy, he's already I mean heap
right?
So five is smaller than seven
and six and seven is smaller
than 9.
So I don't need to do anything,
so this itself is my final
answer.
Yeah.
Is that correct?
All of you.
This tree is the final tree.
This itself is a final correct.
This and this is actually the
same only right?
I checked here and it was
already, you know, five is
smaller than seven and six,
seven is smaller than mine.
So it's all the same.
Yeah, that's correct.
These two are the same, so I
will stop it.
I will not further do any swaps.
Is what I meant by this diagram.
Is this correct guys?
All of you? Yeah.
So we had a leaf node under 6IN
that case we should have a
swapped it, right?
Yeah.
So in those cases that's
different.
Yeah, you should have.
Again considered and you know
you should have done it the
moment it's some in heap you
will stop there.
Otherwise you'll continue to do
the swaps.
Well, two questions for you
illustrate the result of
inserting the elements one at a
time.
Yeah, this is a new concept now,
right?
So I had initially told you how
many ways are there to build a
heap.
That real quick, guys, either
whatever numbers are given to
me, I can create a complete
binary tree out of it and then I
can apply hippie fication
correct.
For example, if these numbers
are given, I will randomly do
this 3533421014, right?
And then I have 1927 now.
Is this a complete binary tree?
Yes, this is the CBT.
But is this a heap?
Is this any heap?
Can you quickly tell me that?
But if I is greater than 33 N no
42, no.
This seems to be mean he, but
here again there is problematic.
So this is not a heap, right?
So I should be making it a heap.
I want to make a min heap out of
it.
So what algorithm I will apply?
I'll apply meaning hippie fight
on which nodes will apply.
SURBHI will tell that.
I just whatever number was
given, I translated into a
complete binary tree that is not
a heap.
I want a min heap so I will
apply min Heapify but on what
all position should I do that
yeah.
Toby will tell that.
Yeah.
27 is wrong.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
Yeah, I should start doing it in
internal nodes, meaning I should
do it in 42.
I should do it in 33.
I should do it in this so these
positions I should do my
application cool.
That's what you will do and what
you will get.
You will get a heap and in that
perform 2 deletion, meaning two
times you delete that route,
right?
And yeah, these type of
techniques you should not do
like sorting it, inserting it
and all that you should not do
this is the technique.
Yeah, you should not reinvent
the wheel by doing some other
things.
Yeah.
Please keep that in mind.
Don't manipulate anything with
that given data.
If you sort it, you will get
some other type of a tree.
Yeah, perform two delete
operations in that tree.
Delete, meaning you will delete
the route.
You will again put the last node
there.
You will perform all that down
heat bubbling.
You will get it.
Similarly for this question
apply Max Heap, will you be able
to do this?
Yes.
No, maybe.
The bigger exercise you'll have
to create it.
You'll have to delete two times.
You'll have to create it.
You'll have to delete two times,
right?
OK, this is one way.
There's another way where it is
telling you one at a time,
right?
So that is another way to create
a heap.
We will look at it now in some
examples.
Yeah.
Meaning immediately immediately
you will perform the swapping if
needed.
Yeah, we will look at it.
It is called creating a heap by
repetitive insertion.
What about this?
There's another excuse for you.
Consider a binary Max CP
implemented using an array.
Which of them represents a Max
heap?
Such questions you can expect in
the quiz, so each of them you
will translate it into a tree
and then you will see which of
them is a Max heap, and that
option is the correct one.
Others are not Max heaps. Yeah.
Did you all get the question
real quick?
Yeah.
Descending order all that is
wrong.
Yeah, there can be any form
which can be a Max heap.
There is no way you can
recognize that sorted one is
heap and all that.
Yeah.
Don't go by that logics.
Try to translate this into a
tree and see which of them is a
maxim.
Yeah, there is.
I can always give an order which
looks like a descending or, you
know sending, but it might not
be a heap or Max cpia.
Well, that's pretty much, yeah.
So, no, Sir.
Can you explain the question?
Yeah.
The question simply says there
are four arrays.
Which of them is a Max heap?
Array representation right?
So what you should do to solve
such problems is for each of
them you will translate that
into a tree like this, right?
You will translate that and then
you will check is that a Max heap or not.
Right, for all of the four you
will do right?
25 is greater than 141614, is
greater than 16, is greater than
the first one, is a Max heap.
The others also you will draw it
and see if it is really a max heap
or not, right?
Now all of you got the question,
Sir, can we make a tree and
check condition?
Yeah, that's what I did right.
This is a Max heap.
The first one is a Max heap, the
others are not. Actually.
Yeah, with such trivial
questions, you can't expect from
me, right?
I will just give you this much
and I'll ask you how many of
these are heaps, right?
So you should draw all of them
and check right.
Otherwise, the moment you get
the right answer, you will stop
it there.
But I want you to translate all
of them and give me how many
heaps are there out of these.
So for MCQ, all of these you
know tricks you can follow.
Yeah.
So that's pretty much so.
Now, do you all know what is heapification
What is maxi min heap?
Yeah, I'll keep asking.
You will keep telling. Yes. No.
Yeah.
Do you know what is Max heap min
heap?
Yeah, yeah.
VISHAL be spoke about it long
back?
Yeah, fifth slide.
Was that only if there's a heap
directly translated to an array,
that's all.
Yeah, if it's an array translate
into a complete binary tree.
If it is not a heap, perform
heapification.
That's what the whole story we
have been learning, right?
You know what is the Max heap?
You know what is the min heap
right.
Second thing, if a CBT is given
to you, which is what we shall
ask now like can you give me an
example right?
Something like this.
This is an array given to you
translate it into a CPT after
you translate it.
It might automatically be a heap
if it is not a heap.
What will you do?
Yeah.
What should you be doing?
What is that process called?
There was an area given it
translated into a CPT but it is
not a heap.
Then if I want to make it as a
heap, I will perform heapification
yeah, so there's a lot
of terminologies here.
So I want you to remember them
technically you all know it.
It is swap only, but you should
not use that term because we are
doing a masters course, right?
We love jargons. Computing.
Students love jargons, right?
Heapification is the right term.
Heapification is the process of
translating a non heap into a
heap and if I wanted a Max heap
I will perform Max heapify.
You want?
I mean, he help perform mean
heapify problem solved and then
we also learned about what is
insertion and deletion in
deletion.
I can only delete the root and
if I delete it I will place the
last node there and then what
type of bubbling is required.
Yeah.
Simran, Amit, all of you.
Which type of bubbling is
needed?
Yeah, very good down he bubbling
because from root it'll bubble
down.
And what about insertion?
You will insert it at Z which
is the insertion point and then
it may bubble up to its proper
position.
So that is up heap bubbling, so
insertion is upheap, bubbling
deletionist down heap bubbling.
So we learned about all that.
So is this clear?
So far, so far, so good.
All of you heaps?
Yeah, practice all such
questions.
Yeah, only when you draw and you
know all that, you will enjoy
this concepts.
Yeah, keep doing all these sorts
of exercises.
Yeah, you'll actually enjoy
doing that.
So here you are doing upheap
bubbling.
Here you are using down heap
bubbling because this deletion
cool.
That being said, let's get
started with heap sort, right?
Heapsort is one of the
applications of your heap.
Heapsort is one of the best
sorting methods or algorithms
being in place and in no
quadratic worst case scenarios.
What is this in place now?
Right.
So I'll very quickly recap all
this is not there, but you have
to know.
So any sorting algorithm, there
are two properties for it.
Yeah.
One is called in place right in
place, means a sorting algorithm
is set to be in place if it
moves the items within the array
itself, and thus requires only a
small constant extra storage,
right?
So there are two properties for
any sorting algorithm.
One is called in place, one is
called stability.
Yeah.
So stability is a bigger
concept, so I don't want to
touch into all that, but you can
Google about it.
Yeah, stability of a sorting.
Yeah, it revolves around the
relative position and so on, but
in place is important, meaning
in heap sort.
If you give me an array and if
you tell me to sort it, I will
not need some other data
structure.
Of course I'll need some small
variables, but I will not use
some other array, stack, linked
list etc to sort it.
I will use the very same data
structure which is given to me
and I will do the sorting.
Such sorting techniques are
called in place, so do you all
know what is bubble sort?
Is it in place?
But doing bubble sort.
Am I using some other data
structure or I'm just doing some
swaps and doing it?
Yeah, bubble sort is also in
place.
Bubble sort.
Selection sort.
Insertion sort, heapsort et
cetera are in place.
There are some sortings like
merge sort.
Yeah, Merge sort is a sorting
technique which is not in place.
We will learn in this course
later.
At that time you will realize
it.
So far so good, all of you.
Krishna says.
Yeah, I do not know them.
So how do I even answer?
But that's fine.
You understood what is in place,
right?
Any sorting algorithm which is
just swapping within them to get
the sorted order is called in
place.
If I use some other data
structure help then that is not
in place.
So this guy is in place
algorithm.
He'll not need extra space and
time wise.
Also, he's very good because
he's no quadratic meaning in no
case he will have, you know,
N Square, etcetera.
Yeah, he's a good algorithm and
it's a very cool algorithm,
guys.
Yeah, Heapsort is divided into 2
basic parts, creating a heap of
the unsorted list, whatever
number is given to you, just
create a heap out of it.
Yeah.
Then a sorted array is created
by repeatedly removing the
largest or smallest element of
the heap, and now this is a good
time to ask you a question.
I have a Max heap.
Where is the largest element of
that Max heap ?
Take any example.
Yeah, it'll be in the root.
I have a min heap who will be
there in the root, yeah.
Surbhi, others I have
a min heap like this who will be
in the root.
Yeah.
Which element?
What can you comment about
The root element?
Yeah, the minimum element, the
smallest element will be there
in the root.
If it is a min heap, if it is a
Max heap, the largest element
will be there in the root, so
these are some observations or
qualities about the heap.
So I will make use of that
property.
I will remove it.
I will keep removing and what I
get is a sorted order.
So what I mean to say is why to
study heapsort?
Because it's a well known
traditional sorting algorithm,
it's it's been there for like
four or five decades.
It's a very old algorithm.
Heapsort is always big O(n) and
log n, so it's a very good
thing that it guarantees me
whatever be the number,
whatever.
And you give me, I will have
complexity as N log N I will not
go to North Square, N cube
etcetera.
Yeah, but there are some bad
algorithms.
We will look at it after mid SIM
depending on the type of numbers
given, their complexity will
change.
So Heapsort is always clear.
He'll always give and log north
and Heapsort is really a cool algorithm.
Why is it cool?
Why do I say like that?
Well, it's like a kid's play,
right?
I mean, you do 2 things.
You build a heap.
Right.
Whatever numbers we're given to
you, numbers were given you
built a heap out of it, right?
And now remove everything and
what you got is sorted.
Isn't that looking cool for you?
We were given at list of
numbers.
You created a heap out of it.
You removed everything but in
that process.
What you got is sorted order.
Yes, no.
Did you all understand the
philosophy of this sorting?
If you understood this, then
everything falls in place.
You don't need to actually write
the code and you know the whole
working of it, but this is the
philosophy of it.
So every sorting algorithm runs
on a philosophy.
Yeah.
So this is a very cool algorithm
which has two phases, building
it and then removing everything.
Not clear, Krishna ?.
This is a list of numbers given
to you which is not in sorted
order.
The first phases using that
numbers build a heap.
You've built it.
How can you build it?
That in place is the one where
we do not need extra element or
space.
Yes, extra data structure you
don't need meaning in this array
itself.
I can use the sorting, I don't
need another array and other
linked list etcetera.
I don't need.
They are going back to Krishna,
he told us.
Not clear.
So there's a list of numbers.
You built a heap.
How many ways are there to
build?
There are two ways, right?
Either I can just translate this
into a CPT right and then apply
heapification.
That is one way or I can create
it using repetitive insertion,
which is what I'll show you now
one by one.
Each of the element you can
create it into a heap.
Heap is now created.
The first phase is over in that
created heap, delete all the
elements, meaning first delete
the root and then you know you
will perform all that you know
down heap bubbling then some
other you know he could have
got created again.
Delete the root.
Keep doing that.
All nodes will be deleted right?
And what you have got it is a
sorted out.
So we'll take an example.
Given an array of N elements, we
first build the heap.
The largest element is at the
root, but it's position in
sorted array should be the last
if it's we are talking about an
increasing order, correct?
So swap the root with the last
position.
Yeah, we, we will come to this.
You will get it.
Yeah.
With these two are important but
increasing order.
Yeah.
What is increasing order
ascending order for that create
a Max heap for a decreasing
order right from largest too
small.
Create a min heap.
Let's do this.
Heap sort example.
Yeah, let's do this real quick.
We have another 10 more minutes
illustrate heap sort for array
of.
This sorting should be an
increasing order, so if it's an
increasing order, what heap
should I create As for this
slide?
Yeah.
Real quick, guys, increasing
order I want.
I will create a Max heap.
So are the given numbers?
Random numbers?
Or is it already in some sorted
order 4 7 2 1 3?
It is not in any order, right?
It is a random number.
I want to create it in sorting
out, so I will first create a
Max heap first approach of
creating.
You already know correct.
You would have directly
translated this into 4 7 2 1 3 and
then you will apply heapification
on it.
That is one way to create a heap
or there's another way which
some people may like.
I'll first create a four first
number.
Now this is a leaf, so can I
call it as a heap?
Yes, no, this is already a heap.
Now I will insert my 7:00 in the
proper position, which is the
obvious position to the left
side right side, just like a
CBT.
The moment I have added seven
now, is this a keep or not?
Because four is not greater than
7, right?
So it is violating the heap
property, so I will immediately
swap it.
Meaning, I performed a peep
public right.
Immediately it went, got
swapped.
It is now a heap now two I'll
insert.
Where will insert what is the
next zed position, Amit.
Can I add somewhere as the left
or right of four?
Can I add it?
No.
If I add it, it will not become
a heap at all.
So the only position is here.
Yeah, I added two already.
Seven is greater than four, and
two, it's a Max heap.
No problem, right?
What is the next element I
should insert one to the left of
four?
I should insert again.
It's already a heap, right?
Seven is greater than four and
two, four is greater than one,
so there was no need of swap or
upbeat bubbling.
And three, three also inserted
and this is now a maxi.
Are you getting this point all
of you?
This is called building a heap
using repetitive insertion.
So one element after the other
I'm inserting in the proper
position Z and if there is a
need I will perform a app
bubbling.
No, that that is where the trick
is.
Yeah, Kumar, we should not do
that.
Yeah, we will see this example.
You will understand why.
Yeah, if it is a increasing
order, we need the Max heap and
you will understand it.
Why in a moment, let's face it
clear for all of you.
Yes.
No, all of you real quick.
Either you could have taken the
OR other approach to create a
heap or you can use this yeah,
which is nothing but repetitive
insertion.
Yeah, we have built it.
Now I have another slide for
you, right?
This is another way of depicting
so initially so this blue color
means they are all in an array.
This purple color means they are
in a heap, right?
All of you?
Yeah, just a moment.
Yeah, please don't deviate.
We will look at this and then
come back to your questions.
Yeah, initially all of them were
in an array.
The first element went into the
heap, then seven also went into
the heap.
In the second iteration, so
third iteration for the
iteration, 5th iteration.
Finally, all of them are now in
a heap.
This is the heap representation,
correct?
So it's seven is the root four
and two are its children.
One and three are its children,
so first phase is over.
So far so good.
All of you understood this part.
Can you just quickly react?
Yeah.
Perfect.
Now I will perform deletion.
Yeah.
What is the only node that can
be deleted now at this stage?
7 Right focus here.
I should delete that seven and
in that position, who will go?
Yeah, in the normal heap
deletion, if I knock off the
route, the last leaf right, the
last person will go there,
right?
That is what we were doing in
deletion, but in deletion we
were just ignoring the seven,
meaning we were just throwing
him out.
But here we are not going to
throw him out.
We are going to place him in
that empty position.
Yes, look at this.
This is the array
representation.
This is the heap right now.
I will delete that 7.
Now I got the tree like this
right?
Because that last three went
here.
Four is here, 2 is here.
One is here, right?
Is this now a Max heap?
Three is not greater than four
to well.
So what bubbling should I
perform?
This was removal, removal.
Meaning, what bubbling is that?
Yeah, don't heat bubbling right.
This three will bubble down to
its proper position.
Yeah, not a peep bubbling.
Yeah.
OK, but let's look at the array.
So in the array form, if you
denote this three is here and
then you have your 4, you have
your two, you have your one and
seven got deleted, correct?
Is there an empty slot available
for me?
Got it, not.
Right.
Yes, this seven got deleted.
So three game there.
So 3421 is what is the array
representation, but still that
one vacancy is there, which
seven had got removed.
So can I put that seven there
and in an increasing order is 7
in its proper position now.
Now all your questions are
answered.
Someone had asked, you know why
I should use Max sleep?
Because once I delete that root
element, there will be 1 vacancy
at the last position and
actually that is the position
where that element deserves to
be.
So I'll put that seven there.
There's no how many of you got
that instead of justice throwing
that guy?
Put him in that place.
Actually, that is his correct
position.
So now if you see this array
that seven has come here, we'll
we'll proceed ahead.
You will get it.
You know srinivas?
Yeah.
So in this case, what is element
that I should delete?
Yeah, real quick.
Don't leave one element
possible.
Is the root, so I'll delete my
4:00.
And who will go in that
position?
Who will go in that position
real quick?
The last OK, one right one will
go to that position.
So he will create a wide right
in that position.
Go put that four actually.
Right.
So instead of this one, put that
four.
Actually, four is in its proper
position then so I deleted that
4I removed him.
I got my position now 7 instead
of throwing that four, I put him
in that position.
He's correct now.
So there's 312 are still in
heap, but four and seven are in
the sorted output, so it's like
swap root with leaf or something
like that.
Yeah, that's correct.
Cool.
Now in this 312 what should I do
now?
One will get deleted right?
So what is the last guy who will
go there right in that position?
I'll put my 3 right and then
finally you're of one and two
again two will get removed, one
will get removed and your output
will become something like this
and remove that one also.
Meaning, if you look at this in
that diagrammatic form, all of
them were in the heap when this
phase started, then seven alone
got removed, but he went to his
proper position and then in the
next iteration 4 got removed.
He went to his proper position,
then three got removed.
He went to his proper position.
Right.
Two got removed.
He was in the proper position.
One also got removed from the
heap.
He went to the proper position.
So in the 5th iteration, all of
them are in a sorted output.
It is clear for all of you.
Yeah, simple algorithm.
Was step create the heap, second
step remove all of them, but
don't throw him away, but put
him in that empty slot.
Actually that empty slot is the
one where he deserved to be in
the sorted order, right?
So please work this example
again right, without my
presence, without watching the
recording.
Try to do that and you will get
a better hang of it, right?
And how does the algorithm look
like?
The first line is building a Max
sleep and if you clearly observe
the line 2345, what are you
actually doing?
What is this algorithm for?
I want an Indian so to be to
answer this.
If you carefully observe this
part of code, what are we
actually trying to do here?
Yeah, you are always removing
the root only.
Yeah, romik, you're not getting
any position after deletion.
It may not be a heap, so correct
it in the new corrected heap.
Removed the root.
That's what we are.
Keep on doing no clearly.
Observe.
What are we doing?
Are we doing insert here?
No, you are reducing the size of
heap by one.
Yeah, this is nothing but
remove.
Remove algorithm these lines and
first line is building.
So what is the first lines
complexity we go up here and
removal takes log in so totally
it takes this is yen and this
full is a login so it is a total
of and log in after deleting
where to put that removed
element.
How do we find out so that will
be the last position?
Yeah, that'll be the first time.
It will be the last position,
the second time it will be
second last.
That was what I drew in this
diagram.
Yeah, this position then this
position, this position.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Pull again.
There are a lot of exercises for
you, right?
A set of elements have been
given implement heapsort by
showing each step and resultant
must be in the increasing order
if it's increasing order, you
would have created a Max heap.
If decreasing order, you would
have created a min heap every
step just like how we did.
We will use this numbers.
You will create a heap and after
creating you will again remove 1
by 1.
All the root nodes and place
them in their position.
You will get a sorted output.
Yeah.
So log in that we already spoke
removal is removal from a heap
is nothing but login complexity,
right?
Yes, no.
Because it can bubble all the
way down till they leave and the
height of a complete binary
trees log N so remove a list log
north complexity.
Yeah, there are some other
questions as excises.
I want you to, you know, uh,
look into these.
But let me just quickly ask you
one question alone to check if
you have understood something.
All of you focus just for a
minute.
Then I'll leave you free for the
day.
I have a Max.
Yeah.
What do we have?
I have a Max heap with me.
Is there is no numbers at all,
but I know this is the maximum.
I'm telling you, this is a maxi.
I want to know where the second
largest element is.
What is the complexity of it?
Yeah.
What is your thought process?
Who is residing in this
position?
Who's there?
Here is very important guys who
is there in that position.
Forget about this example, I'm
just talking about a general
concept in this root node.
If it is a Max heap who is
present, the largest element?
Very good.
Yeah, nine out of 10 students
will make KRISHNA's mistake.
Don't make that the second
largest element can either be
here or here, because there is
no relation between left and
right child right?
For example 1098.
This is also a Max heap 1089.
This is also a Max heap, so you
cannot comment about is the
second largest is there in left
or right.
You cannot do that, but
definitely you can tell that
second largest element, he said.
This level one and you do that?
Yes.
No.
Maybe now I'm asking you where
is the 4th largest element in
this tree?
Can you tell me where that 4th
largest will be?
Definitely among these three,
the first, second, third are
gone.
So the 4th largest element
should be somewhere in this
level, correct?
I definitely know he will be
either here or here or here or
here, but he will be here only
thought.
Can I not go directly to that
positions in my array and check
them?
And does it give me a better
complexity?
It is actually constant
complexity.
I'll just go look at these two
elements if I want the second or
third largest.
If I want the 4th largest, I
will just look at these four
positions, right?
But if it was not a heap, if it
was not normal array or
something, I should do a
complete traversal which is a
big of yen complexity.
Yeah.
Now, do you all understand the
power of heap?
In other words, this question
asks you to find the K the
smallest element.
If it is a KTH smallest, what
you will do is you will remove K
-, 1 number of times, and then
the KTH smallest will become the
root.
Did you understand what I just
said?
If I want the KTH smallest or
Keith the largest, I will
perform deletion, K -, 1 number
of times randomly.
Then that Keith smallest would
have become the root, and that
is my answer, right?
So heap is much more than what
you think.
It's a very, very powerful
concept.
I just touched the basics for
you, but ponder about these
aspects and you will enjoy
learning about it.
Yeah.
So that's pretty much for today.
We will get started with one of
the other applications of heaps
which is called priority queues
and also about graphs in the
next class.
God, that's pretty much for
today.
Thank you so much.
And see you again the next
Saturday, which is, uh 30th, I
believe.
Yeah, I'm not sure how many of
you will turn up, but you there?
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
I'll stop the recording and I'll
stay for a couple of more
minutes.